mais quelqu'un dont on a beaucoup parlé
cette semaine c'est djamel alors tu
monde en parle personne n'en sait rien
alors on a demandé un ami à lui qui
s'appellera liddell candélie de venir
nous en parler voici khalid al candélie
bonsoir c'est tout le monde a alors vous
êtes 38 ans vous êtes un ami djamel vous
êtes connus où et comment diamal j'ai
connu une petite dizaine d'années donc
il avait il avait 13 ans à peu près et
donc j'ai connu à trappes dans sa cité
attrape coup j'étais intervenu parce
qu'il ya un petit problème
j'étais intervenu pour servir de
médiateur pour essayer d'arranger les
choses oui c'est ça c'est augustin l'ex
champion de kick-boxing à la retraite
alors 13 est président d'une association
sport insertion vous occuper aussi du
téléthon banlieue avec france 2 vous
êtes médiateur médiateur national à la
jeunesse un consultant à la croix rouge
enfin vous êtes tout ce qu'on appelle un
grand frère quoi voilà voilà ça tout ça
je dirais tout ça c'est des choses avec
chose
en effet en plus mais mais sinon je suis
moi même dans le domaine audiovisuel
voilà ouais alors vous êtes quelqu'un
d'assez respecter ça vous a demandé de
devenir d'autant plus que vous avez été
mêlée malgré vous dimanche dernier à la
faire ce qu'on peut appeler la sphère
jamel donc on va voir d'abord un petit
peu de quoi il retourne ensuite on va
voir votre implication dans la sphère et
puis une tentative d'explication
quand je raconte pour les nos amis
téléspectateurs qui sont pas
obligatoirement au courant de toute la
sphère samedi 1er janvier
djamel va une soirée maghreb à bercy au
popb 8000 personnes
il monte sur scène il souhaite la bonne
année il s'en va vers 23h15 dans l'ennui
c'est une mercedes mais ces 4 4 mais
c'est pas ça et c'est le cas et alors là
il ya eu un incident avec les avec les
forces de l'ordre alors la version de
jamel c'est qu'il a été tabassé un coup
de talkie walkie disait son assistante
la version de la police c'est qu'il a eu
un comportement agressif
voilà pour la faire bon alors vous le
dimanche 2 vous allez à l'hôpital
saint-antoine pour le raisonner et vous
avez une altercation d'abord avec nadia
donc l'assistante de djamel celle qui a
déclaré qu'il avait été battu à coups de
talkie walkie
et puis aussi vous avez été frappé et
mordue et mordue par le garde du corps
de jamel qui n'est autre que le frère de
son assistante nadia c'est presque ça
non mais dis si je me suis trompé et
vous avez déposé une plainte au
commissariat du 12e temps tu peut
tromper vers la fin par l'absence et
c'est à dire c'est à dire
qu'effectivement j'ai j'ai vu cette
image terrible est horrible de djamel je
dirais par terre à la télévision donc
j'ai tout de suite je me suis tout de
suite rendu à l'hôpital
effectivement je me suis retrouvé
d'abord dans un premier temps confrontés
à comment dire aux frères de
l'assistante nadia maureen qui ont menti
moment et pourquoi j'étais venu là
j'étais venu dans un double but c'est un
premier but c'était de ça de connaître
l'état de santé de jamel et d'un second
but essaie de comprendre ce qui s'est
passé pour éventuellement voir si on
peut apaiser les choses parce que je
trouvais que ça prenait l'ampleur trop
importante
ce discours là il a été très bien
accepté par l'anc de jamel qui lui si
vous voulez que les choses s'arrangent
il était très mal acceptée par par
l'entourage donc nadia maureen qui elle
voulait que ça s'envenime puisque à la
base elle était un petit peu à la base
de cela et à partir de là comme il
connaissait tous ne connaissent assez
bien quand même donc
ils ont voulu m'interdire l'entrée de la
chambre de jamal donc j'ai demandé à ce
que ces biens jamal qui n'interdisent et
on m'a dit non
le garde du corps en question a fini par
m'avouer que c'était nadia maureen et
puis et puis comme il était un peu gêné
de mater dire la chambre un moment bon
un moment il la seule chose qui la
trouvaient faire c'est de se jeter sur
moi et puis de m'accrocher comme un
pitbull parce qu'en ce moment là
d'accepter des pitbulls aussi de
mattrach et quand même pitbull et de ses
5 vous avez là voilà c'est un peu
maquillée mais est donc et de et de
mordre à 100 bon ça s'est un peu
rétablie maintenant mais le jour même
j'étais quand même affreux mais il
aurait pu vous arracher le manceau basse
esquissé ce qu'ils cherchaient parce que
c'était la seule façon mon parce que il
ya eu déjà un premier une première
tentative j'ai remis à sa place
rapidement en lisons là je suis pas venu
ici pour me donner en spectacle dans un
hôpital il ya comment dire il ya des
médecins il ya des malades et des
malades voyez des médecins il ya des
malades dans le couloir ce qu'ils
avaient et puis avait des enfants
donc c'est pas le cpt pas les deux et
s'il y avait vraiment quelque chose à
faire et aucun problème des coups de
poing des coups de pieds ça fait 30 ans
que j'en donne ça ne dérange pas nier
d'en donner dans ni d'en prendre
donc on pouvait le faire à un autre
moment voilà et puis bon et et puis
après cela bon effectivement comme mon
état le médecin sur place malgré
l'urgence des urgences et puis après bon
c'était parti quand vous alliez en fait
pour arranger les choses et vous êtes
fait mordre
je suis ce film a alors là dessus c'est
vrai que là dessus djamel pour moi il
n'avait rien à voir là dedans puisque
après après tout ça pour aller très très
vite
il m'a appelé il m'a appelé pour comment
dire pour s'excuser de ce qui s'est
passé qu'il en était désolé tout ça et
c'est vrai que quand j'ai discuté avec
lui il
je dis tu sais j'ai mal vu ce que tu es
aujourd'hui je te connais très bien il
faut pas qu'on te donne l'image que tu
n'as pas parce que quelques jamais c'est
quelqu'un de super besse avec un
adorable
c'est un gamin issu des quartiers qui
acquit à comment dire qu'il ya qui a
mangé de la vache enragée pour arriver
là où d'arrivée moi je l' ai connus
quand il avait 13 ans et et c'est
surtout quelqu'un qui ne méritent pas
l'image qu'on veut lui donner
aujourd'hui et qui ne mérite pas
l'entourage qu'il a aujourd'hui
et ce qui est ce qui est incroyable
c'est que depuis 10 mois ça c'est son
papa qui me l'a dit parce qu'il m'a
appelé parce que son papa aussi les
gêner parce que justement comme j'ai
porté plainte
je dirais j'ai presque porter plainte
par rapport à lui pour lui rendre
service et lui et parce que je voulais
montrer l'exemple justement alors rallye
de jamel a été entendu nadia sur
l'assistante a été entendu
sa soeur enfin la soeur de la dia fatima
le frère de jamel karim tu as entendu
par la police des polices par dgs est
dire l été rattrapé un feu rouge c'est
ce qu'il dit il était sorti du véhicule
et le policier lui a fait une clé à son
à son bras handicapé il a été frappé à
la tête à coups de matraque au ventre il
est tombé sur le sol alors là où il ya
quelque chose de pas très clair c'est
qu'en fait nadia disait que c'est un
coup de talkie walkie des coûts de
talkies-walkies sur la nuque et lui a
déclaré que c'était un coup de matraque
dans le ventre donc même la faire et pas
très très clair parce qu'on sait pas
vraiment ce qui s'est passé en fait ce
soir là au moins vous vous les ayant
approché ayant approché l'entourage de
djamel de plus près peut-être vous
connaissez mieux l'histoire c'est à dire
que bon c'est vrai que cette histoire
lll et elle est mal parti allait mal
parti et puis après jamais il n'a pas
besoin de publicité
ça pulse t il à cette publicité il est
archi connus et pour moi ce qui est
important c'est que ce gamin là je veux
pas qu'on grille parce que au niveau des
quartiers
c'est quelqu'un qui ait connus reconnus
respectés je vous donne juste une petite
anecdote les petits gamins que des
petits gamins dans le quartier
maintenant ils ont le look jamal se dire
qu'ils mettent la main dans la poche à
la main elle est en cap et ça c'est
quand même incroyable
donc à partir de partir de là mais
combien marque
il a marqué cette jeunesse et on peux
pas alors quand j'ai eu jamal je lui
expliquais que tu sais déjà même si les
fuites pendant les policiers l'ont
arrêté et pas problème il tarde est même
si tu trouves quitteront quittons
peut-être mal parler ils te demandent
d'arrêter tu t'arrêtes il demande de
donner tes papiers tu te donnes tes
papiers et insultes tu encaisses ils
disent n'importe quoi tu encaisses mais
après décaissement du têt papier tu
fermes ta voiture tu prends direction le
procureur de la république où tu prends
direction la préfecture de police et une
dépose plainte et parce que tu
t'appelles jamal on sera obligé de
prendre ta plaque parce qu'on saura que
s'il se vend l'apprend pas communiqué
dessus et quand tu auras peut déposer sa
plainte
là tu peux communiquer dire voilà moi
jamel debbouze issus des quartiers
je suis un citoyen comme tout le monde
et j'ai déposé plainte parce que j'ai je
j'ai trouvé comment maltraité sur et je
veux montrer l'exemple à tous les gamins
hélas est un bon exemple
et ces essais ce côté-là succès ce soir
là que je l'expliqué avec un crime en
clair il ya le policier qui a dit que
jamais de gesticuler dans tous les sens
pour fait ça il fait ça tout le temps
ouais bien sûr mais qu'il avait vu sur
scène ils verraient que c'est la turquie
chez lui de gesticuler dans tous les
sens alors ils lui ont donc ils ont vu
que ces papiers tes parents il est
maintenant ils cherchent à l' emmerder
bien entendu ils disent que il a pas son
père mais en fait le permis est caduc
que son véhicule ait pas équipés pour
son handicap
voilà donc c'est vrai que maintenant il
va l'emmerder de toute façon c'est pour
cette raison que je dirais pour pour
l'entourage mois de mai le plus beau
témoignage ce que j'ai vu c'était le
carnage du papa de diamal il m'a il m'a
appelé parce que il m'a dit il mais dit
écoute parce que jamal voulait que je
retire ma plainte et je et j'expliquais
que tu es pour son intérêt à lui moi
j'irai c'est pas un c'est pas un
problème si je ne sais pas une morsure
qui va me faire quelque chose de vote de
plus mais c'est le principe puisque je
suis venu pour les montres et pour qui
montre l'exemple
à moi de montrer l'exemple citoyens moi
j'ai jamais porté plainte de ma vie
j'espère qu'ils veulent comprendre
j'espère mais ce qui est dommage c'est
que mon par rapport par exemple par
rapport à son papa et m'a dit écoute
khalid je sais que jamel c'est ton petit
frère et je sais que tu lui feras jamais
de mal mais c'est vrai que actuellement
depuis une dizaine de mois depuis qu'il
a ce nouvel entourage
ça passe à part ça part très mal là je
suis vraiment très content parce que je
suis assis à côté de laëtitia
comme djamel tissage est vu par était
gamine parce que je prends très bien
sympa mais c'est parce que depuis
longtemps alors laetitia vous qui
connaissez
khalid qui connaissait djamel vous
pensez quoi de cette affaire j'étais pas
là donc je vais pas je ne sais pas
personne peut raconter ce qui s'est
passé puisque la version évidemment sont
pas les mêmes mais sur le fond parce
qu'il est connu aussi on s'acharne cc
c'est pareil quoi céder parce qu'il
s'appelle jamel debbouze si ça plait je
sais pas moi n'importe quoi on connaît
pas il est pas connue je pense pas qu'on
en aurait fait tout un fromage et tout
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
d'effervescence autour de cette histoire
et je pense que tout ce qu'a dit
khalid c'est vrai quoi c'est dis pas de
bêtises comme moi je le connais depuis
petit comme il y est
et puis c'est quelqu'un de gentil et qui
fait beaucoup pour les autres donc et
jamel est un garçon extraordinaire moi
je l'avais vu deux jours avant que ce
soit passé cette histoire et c'est un
garçon qui est plein de vie c'est un
garçon qui est jean qui est qui qui
aiment les autres et qui là pour faire
rire
à la base c'est ce que je me fais rire
à la base on air on est des artistes
qu'on soit chanteur acteur comique ou
quoi que ce soit on est là pour faire du
bien aux gens et pour sortir les gens de
leur quotidien
dès qu'il nous arrive un tout petit
dérapage tout le monde s'acharne sur
nous et c'est automatiquement on nous
donne une image qui n'est pas la nôtre
et on est obligé de on peut pas trop se
défendre non plus c'est pour ça qu'on
parle pas parce que plus on en parle et
plus ça remue et puis on s'en sort pas à
quoi donc à rien on peut rajouter aussi
que curieusement dans le même temps
quelqu'un devait être sur les côtes
bretonnes
il n'y était pas dans son dans le temps
imparti
pendant ce temps là y avait des jeunes
gens de confessions différentes sic qui
sont partis pour ramasser le zouk sur
les côtes tout à fait prête à fait
dormir
rebondit un petit peu sur richard
chabran j'ai c'est que j'irai nous notre
combat puisque vous parlez des confrères
nous donne combat de nous notre combat
un petit peu c'est d'essayer
je dirais d'honorer le sacrifice de nos
parents nos parents ils sont venus dans
ce pays pour nous apporter ce qu'il
pouvait pas ne pas d'apporter nos pays
d'origine
ils ont laissé leur santé ils ont cessé
leur jeunesse pour nous c'est pas pour
qu'aujourd'hui on voit leurs enfants
dans les faits divers c'est tout c'est
ça le sait ça le combat il pour être sûr
de ne rien rater
le in a l'habitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux